Matt starts us off from Montana this
hour hey Matt how are you good how you
doing sir better than I deserve what's
up and you I knew that answer was coming
well I'll give you the kind of the quick
synopsis a homebuilder here in Montana
got my butt handed to me and the
recession and I've been working my way
out it was in the middle of a big
commercial and residential subdivision
when the recession hit that of course
went on hold and now I'm still digging
out and digging out personally as of
right now paid off about 450,000
personally Wow I sell in my cell in my
house selling basically everything but
the kids Wow and changing our lives I
mean the life we took your class at a
church here in town and that drastically
drastically changed our lives so we
thank you for that but where I'm sitting
today is I'm down to personally 102,000
personally and on my house that I
rebuilt after I sold my other house and
that's mostly just my land I paid
basically just on the house as I've gone
so it sitting really good personally
that way so you have a hundred and two
thousand dollar mortgage on your home
correct yeah okay and have bhakta kick
uh my student loans gone down about the
last forty two hundred on that so that's
going to be gone here in about another
month wow man you're killing it
congratulations oh thank you thank you
and then in the meantime we decided to
have two more kids and now we're up to
six kids so busy lives in the process of
everything wife started a business
debt-free and doing really really well
with that just haven't drawn income off
of it just keep rolling it into the
business rolling it into the business
and now we're going to start pulling
consistently about six to seven thousand
a month off of that business cool so
yeah
or you might want your anthem my income
building now kind of post-recession I'm
making 67 the 70s a year just myself
before the wife's income sounds like
you're but all together going to have
about a hundred and a half cent okay
I'm basically starting from this point
forward with the wife's um deal yeah
what what I'm working on now is I had
about seven million vote on my
subdivision down to about two and a half
as its back going and getting developed
and sold and keeping the housing market
going so working to never ever ever be
back in debt that much I really have you
still have that yes still have that
business debt so working through that
with what I've got going for did melt
development wise got probably about
three and a half million won stuff is
final platitude in this spring so we'll
have that paid off and knock on wood
have about a million million and a half
to show for it depending on you know
interest in taxes and all that great
stuff okay so the properties are going
to sell off at the current burn rate by
spring and you will be debt-free and if
I'm gonna have cleared a million dollars
yep good where to go
that's a funny I want to turn around
yeah that's quite the turnaround and
that still would have probably about
five commercial properties debt-free at
that point that I could continue to sell
or the idea what to keep and you know
but commercial businesses on them for at
least that kind of thing are they paid
for or they can they would they would be
by next spring summer hood so there'd be
clear okay yep yeah so where I'm sitting
today and that's why I'm having to
cultivate that guru here is a got a
fella that I have worked with for lots
of years built a commercial building in
our subdivision bought the Lots from us
and built a commercial building he's
wanting to sell the building now and
I've been basically managing it for him
he wants to sell it to me work as the
bank set up as a trust indenture not a
contract
and I just important I don't know if
it's worth getting back in some form of
debt again no it's not okay haven't you
had enough fun no no I I guess I haven't
no I mean I definitely have had way way
too much fun
listen I got I got a bunch of commercial
property and I own all of it free and
clear and life is good and light has get
the last thing I want that young
mortgage I mean I don't I don't need a
piece of property I don't need a deal of
any kind ever again bad enough to go
into debt for it so what is the what's
this property worth that this guy's want
to sell you
ah its appraised at a million 380 well
can't you pay cash for it next spring
basically that's kind of the idea here
is a lease it was an option until next
spring oh yeah he wants to get rid of it
now he just wants to be done he's out of
the area then you're not the buyer okay
if he wants to lease it to you till next
spring with an option to purchase I
might give him a little money for that
you know to hold it until I've got the
money but I don't have the money and so
I'm not a player listen it is cleaned up
my life Matt my brain my brain is so
clean because it's a real simple
transaction I look at something and if I
have the money I can buy it if I don't
have the money I can't buy it because I
don't borrow money yeah and that's
exactly what I've done for five years
and you cleaned up a whole dadgum mess
that that almost took them down man I
mean your whole was in the Neuse and you
got your head out of the news yeah don't
stick it back in there okay what what I
need to hear cuz you know I I feel an
entrepreneur I still see like a good
deal like hey real estate guy I love a
good deal man yeah I love a good deal
but there's no possible way I'm going
back into debt the definition of a good
deal it partly is can I pay for it true
and you're not ready listen I I'll give
you a bet all right I'll give you
50 50 percent shot or greater this guy
waits till spring to sell it to you okay
I'll bet you're probably right because
that's basically what my wife said -
yeah you take an option on it you run it
for him till spring you make him a sweet
deal and you cash out your deal and you
put the cash and go buy the property if
it's a great Buy and if it's something
you really want to own but if I got a
million dollars in my hand or million
three in my hand I want to look at that
piece of property and go is this what I
want to buy do you really are you sure
it's that good a day that's a lot of fun
are you sure because I'm gonna get I
mean if it's were only worth a million
three certainly don't want buy it for a
million three I want a pie you know
let's be worth to me if I'm paid a
million three points so I really want a
good deal here because I'm walking
around with cash and you know cash tops
man and you know what else walks right
so that that just you know don't don't
do it unless you got the cash structure
it in a way where your head doesn't go
back in the news my man don't just learn
the lesson don't go back this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you